you've since retired from acting I can
still see that you you have a passion
for the craft it sounds like because I
remember I talked with you a couple
years ago and you had said that trying
to be a working actor in this town is
like chasing fool's gold or something to
that effect and that always stayed with
me I'm probably paraphrasing no because
the idealism and the passion that you
have for acting when you're young and
you're starting and you're in your early
20s and it means everything to you it's
life and death it was that way for me
and my friends anyway the people that I
was coming up with and studying with the
desire to express yourself was so been -
and the passion for acting was born out
of something that was really pure and
you did it from all these you know
sometimes infer your passions your views
political personal whatever you put it
all into this this this art right but as
you get into the business and you start
going down that path you start to
understand that this is a business and
to to become a there's many levels to
success in this business you can become
the leading man you can become the bit
actor you can become the character actor
there's many paths what I meant by that
statement that sometimes it's like
chasing fool's gold
is you wind up doing all of this work
and love of art and the craft and and to
then end up doing nachos commercials
right and that becomes your day that's
part of the reality of sometimes being a
professional mainstream working actor
not a famous one not one that anybody's
but that you grind out your living year
after year in the business that was my
reality I made
between 65 and 130 thousand a year for
about 16 years that is a different story
than being a guy that's on a show or
book some thing that's a very different
narrative it's a very different
lifestyle it's a very different anxiety
that you have to live with so you have
to wake up at the start of every year at
zero there is no security you don't have
a show you don't have a job you don't
have you on your own to go out and get
your work and that's why it's so
pivotally important that you know
yourself so well and are comfortable and
confident in who and what you're trying
to do and that you nurture that nurture
that because no one outside of that is
going to give you anything you have to
go out and get it and nobody's looking
to hire people that when they walk in
the room are being asked you know of the
people please make me feel okay they
want to hire the person that walks in
the room and says I'm here to make you
feel okay I do my job for you you have
to own that you have to have that to to
to to have a career so it's a very tough
life once you're trying to to have a
life pay your bills and be be a
professional actor and face the
rejection everything you get five
auditions a week you book none of them
week after week after week you have to
learn to psychologically and emotionally
adjust to that so that out of that
people become desperate people start
then just chasing you know obsessively
the you know
the commercial or the the the the
concept of booking you know something
were you having to spend the day with a
with a tire around your belly and
flip-flops while you're you know selling
Vaseline commercial you know whatever it
becomes that's what I meant by fool's
gold some of the things we have to do I
think get quite ridiculous
you